- My worry is this.
If I had, and I've said
this on "Bar Rescue",
there's 60 motorcycles in front of a bar,
there's a bunch of people
that won't go to that bar.
If there's a bunch of people
dressed in gang colors
in front of a bar, there's
people who won't go in that bar.
Today, if there's a bunch
of people in front of a bar
that look irresponsible
as it relates to COVID,
there are customers that
won't go in that bar.
It's no different.
(serious music)
- This is "The Rubin
Report" and I'm Dave Rubin.
Reminder, everybody, to
subscribe to our YouTube channel
and tap that notification
bell so you see our new videos
in your feed.
And joining me today is the host
and Executive Producer of "Bar Rescue",
the Chairman and CEO of Taffer Dynamics,
and creator of "NFL Sunday",
I didn't know that one,
Jon Taffer, welcome to "The Rubin Report".
- Good to be here, Dave.
- I am really glad to
be talking to you today,
because as you know, we're kicking off
a small business week here,
and I'm gonna be talking
to business owners all
over the country and I
think at least one in Canada
about how to reopen, how to
get business going again,
how to get the economy going
again and everything else,
and I thought you'd be a fun
guy to kick this off with.
So first off, I can see you're sitting
in front of a bar right there.
Where are ya?
What's going on in your
world at the moment
before we get into business?
Well, this is my, I'm in my home bar,
in my home in Las Vegas.
So this is, which I've
turned into a studio lately.
We have, our company
is based here in Vegas,
I've lived here in Vegas
for about eight years,
and we moved all of our
equipment here to my house.
So I've been working from home.
I think I'm on my 93rd day at home
since we closed down production.
Now, I'll go out on occasion.
I've done one or two remotes
for some news channels.
I've did a couple of Fox pieces,
I did an MSNBC piece where we went out
on the Strip and did it.
But I've maintained serious distances.
And I'm one of the more cautious ones
in our society, I think.
- Yeah, so I was reading a bit about that.
So you are definitely on the
more cautious side of it.
But I suspect as a guy like you,
who you like getting out there
and going across the country
and talking to people, and
sometimes yelling at people
and getting pretty emotional with people.
You must kinda miss that,
that human interaction thing, right?
- Oh, big time.
Matter of fact, Dave, and
I haven't told anyone this.
I'll tell you this today.
I have a 45-foot tour bus,
and I'm leaving next Tuesday
to go across the country
in my bus.
- Oh, wow.
- And I'm doing it just to get out there.
I can see some family along the way,
but it's a safe way to travel these days.
So I'll be out there and traveling
around the country for the
next three to five weeks.
- So how did the whole
shut down affect production
for "Bar Rescue"?
Were you guys producing right now,
or were you in a break, or
are you coming back soon?
Where are you at?
- No,
we were actually producing,
and right in the middle
of our last episode.
We had eight more to do for the season.
We were doing, I think,
28 for this season.
And the first of the last episode,
we started to sense things were going on.
We changed our production style.
I was separated from customers.
We changed camera angles and stuff
to try to make it all work.
And at the end of that
episode we were given a choice
to, by the network to
either proceed or not.
And we chose to proceed for another week.
But then, about three hours later
we got the call from the network
that everything was being closed down.
And that was about 93 days ago.
So we shut that down,
we had eight more left
on the schedule, and everybody
scattered and went home.
- So I don't know what
you'll make of this,
but I have only watched two reality shows
in my entire life.
I watched "The Apprentice" with Trump,
and I watch "Bar Rescue" with you.
So I'm not sure what that means
about the company that you keep,
but there is something about
"Bar Rescue" that it just,
it checks off all the boxes for me.
Because it's very human,
it's dealing with struggle,
it's dealing with finances,
it's dealing with, often
with family interactions,
personal interactions,
business, the whole thing.
Where did the idea for the
show originally come from?
I mean, I know you've been
in that world forever,
but really, the genesis of the show?
- Well, I've been, as you've said,
I've been in the industry
for a long, long time.
And I had the most popular seminars
in the industry before I was on TV.
And I gave a speech in
Vegas at Caesar's Palace,
and at the end of the speech,
somebody came up to me, Dave, and said,
"You should be on TV".
So I wrote up this thing
that was originally called,
"On the Rocks", and it was a little
like "Mission Impossible".
It started with me with files,
and I'd pull out the mixologist,
and then I'd pull out the chef,
sort of like "Mission Impossible" started,
and then I'd go in and do these rescues.
And I knew I had an advantage
because I wasn't a chef.
So I didn't migrate to the kitchen.
I went everywhere.
So I focused much more on other areas
of the business than a chef did.
I wrote this up.
And I had done business
with Paramount before
in the restaurant space as a licensee.
So I went back to my friends
who ran Paramount Television
with my writeup and I
was really excited, Dave.
And they looked at me, they said,
"Jon, you'll never be on television.
You're too old, you're
not good looking enough,
it'll never happen."
So I went and I shot my own sizzle reel
the next week with some friends,
in Redondo Beach at a friend's bar
and sent that sizzle reel
to four production companies
who I had no relationship with.
Just emailed it to their
development people.
And I got four offers within three weeks.
So I then navigated through those offers,
and I wasn't in the television business,
so I didn't understand run clauses,
and all the likeness right clauses,
and all the things that are particular
to an entertainment contract.
So I got myself an entertainment manager
and an entertainment lawyer,
and we put the deal together,
and in less than a year from
when that person told me
I'd never be on TV, the show premiered.
We're now 196 episodes in,
we're four episodes from 200,
which is a big record in my industry.
Show has generated now, I think it's close
to $800 million dollars worth of revenue,
and it's one of the most
successful reality shows
of all time.
And it just shows, don't give up, Dave.
When somebody else says no, maybe the yes
should be stronger in your own mind.
- Yeah, well, that's such a
consistent message in the show.
But I'm here in LA.
For people that don't
know how this biz works,
the idea that you sent four blank pitches,
not that were asked for
or came from an agency
and got four responses back, I mean,
that's gotta be unheard of.
I assure you, I've sent enough pitches
to these people to know
that that's pretty good.
- Well, I guess sometimes
it's timing, Dave.
But I guess I didn't
realize it at the time,
but 196 episodes into this, I
guess I'm pretty good at it.
And my secret has been
to resist production
from the get go.
And I'm different than a
lot of reality TV stars.
And Trump, I think, was this
was in "Celebrity Apprentice".
He already had his money.
I already had my success.
So I wasn't gonna sell my
soul to be on television.
It was gonna be real or
I wasn't gonna do it.
So the behind-the-scenes in
"Bar Rescue" is almost nil.
I get no briefing, I
don't watch any videos.
I don't go to the places in advance,
I've never met the people before.
I get about a 60-second briefing
right before I get into the SUV,
and everything else, I
learn it when you do.
And I think that's why
the show is successful,
'cause you'll know fake in a second, Dave.
- Yeah, well, one of the things
I've heard you say is that
fixing bars is easy,
fixing people is hard.
Did you realize going into
it how much of it was just
gonna be dealing with, like,
the psychology of people?
Because usually that seems
to be what you're fixing.
You go in and fix the bar after,
but you're really fixing the people first.
- And that was sort of
an evolution, honestly.
Because when I started
this I was a consultant.
And I was a very well-known consultant.
So I had very well-known clients.
So my clients are people
like Marriott Corporation,
and Holiday Inns, Inc. and
Fridays, companies like that.
So I never knew this level of
failure even existed, Dave.
I never saw anything like
this before in my life.
So when I said to the
network, "I want you guys,
find me real failures.
I don't want this easy,
let's make this real."
I never comprehended this.
I mean, to think that
somebody's 50 years old,
a half a million dollars in debt,
living in your parent's
basement with their child,
losing $30,000 a month,
out of money, no credit,
and they're still going, it's remarkable.
And most of these people
have two to three weeks left
and then they're done anyway.
So it really is a last chance for them.
- So I know I could do the whole hour
on "Bar Rescue" with you,
but how much of the interactions, like,
I get you're being real and
you just learned from them.
Do you sense, it's always this thing
where you see people suddenly
doing these crazy things
right before we started.
I said I was watching one
yesterday doing cardio
where there's this woman
who is an owner of a bar,
she's probably in her mid-50s.
She's got big boobs, she's
got people doing shots
off her rack, like, some
of it seems like it's,
like, too crazy to be real.
And yet, I suspect is probably isn't.
- Well, no, it's completely real.
Everything is completely real.
There are no actors, there's no scripts,
there's no reshoots.
It is completely real.
And when I looked at her,
and I hope I can say this
on this podcast, when
I look at her and said,
"I can help your sagging business,
I don't know if I can
help your sagging boobs",
I said that to her for a reason.
I wanted to embarrass her.
And when I started "Bar Rescue", Dave,
it was all about dirty bars, and remodels.
And several episodes into it I realized
how flawed these owners were
to be in those situations.
And if I didn't change them,
I couldn't change anything.
And it was about 120 episodes in,
believe it or not, I
was in Detroit, Michigan
with a female owner of a bar
I think I named the Pruding Grounds.
And I looked at her and I
said, "Why are you failing?"
And Dave, she looked at me
in the eyes and said to me,
"I am failing because
of the euro in Greece."
This was in suburban Detroit, Michigan.
And at that moment I realized
that 120 times earlier
I had asked these business
owners why are they failing,
and never once, Dave, did anyone ever look
at me and said failing because of me, Jon.
Not once.
So I realized, wait a minute.
If she goes home and blames
the euro on her failure,
she has no reason to change.
She'll look in the mirror in
the morning and she'll say,
"That damn euro taking me down!"
But if she looked in the mirror and said,
"I'm failing because of
me", she wouldn't like that.
She would change.
That hit me a couple of years
ago, or three years ago.
And I realized that excuses
are the common denominator of failure.
And then I thought to
myself a little farther,
"What is an excuse?"
An excuse is the
reconciliation of a mistake.
Either you did something
you shouldn't have,
you didn't do something you should have,
or you screwed up or you
wouldn't need the excuse.
So an excuse is your way of
making yourself feel good
about your own failure.
It's the most paralyzing thing
in business is an excuse.
So when I realized that, I said to myself,
"Wow, I think I found a common
denominator of failure."
If I can get excuses out of people,
I can take the things away
from them that paralyze them,
that cause them to hesitate and pause.
So then I said,
"What are the biggest
excuses that we deal with?"
Well, fear is a big one.
I'm scared to do it, I'm scared to do it.
But what we're scared
of, millions of people
have already done.
I'm not talking about standing
on the edge of a cliff,
obviously, Dave, but in business and risk,
I mean, these aren't new things, fear.
Other people have already done this.
Fear is BS in my view.
And then I look at scarcity.
Well, I don't have the money.
Well, tell that to Steven
Jobs in his garage.
Scarcity.
And then I love the excuse, circumstance.
Well, it's a recession.
I can't make money was
the big one years ago.
People got rich during the recession.
A lot of people did.
So during our pandemic,
look at how hand sanitizer companies,
and mask companies, look
at how these industries,
somebody's making money
during all of these things.
And then I looked at the other excuses.
And I came up and I realized that if I can
take these excuses out of people's lives,
I can stop what paralyzes them.
That all happened in that Detroit episode.
And from that I wrote the book,
"Don't BS Yourself,
Cut the Excuses That
Are Holding You Back",
which made it to "The New
York Times" Best Seller list,
and I'm very, very proud of that book,
because when you finish it,
excuses won't work for you anymore.
Now you're self-accountable.
Now, when you look in a
mirror in the morning,
you will blame yourself.
And you should.
- Yeah, well, and that's what seems
to be the consistent message
throughout the shows,
that the owner usually is
making all sorts of excuses
for all sorts of things.
And if you can fix that guy or that girl,
then the rest of the
pieces do fall into place.
Do you guys ever do look backs
where you're trying to figure out,
who actually succeeded after this?
Or who, the next day after
they go their brand new,
beautiful bar, just
screwed up the whole thing,
because I'm sure that happens, too.
- Yeah, there's a website
called "Bar Rescue" Updates.
It's an independent website.
We have nothing to do with it.
It tracks the success of "Bar Rescue".
And of course, now everybody's closed,
but pre-pandemic, we were tracking
at about 68 to 70% success factor.
Now, I don't know what their
definition of success was,
Dave, if it's open three
years later, or two years,
I don't know, but I know
that they had us tracking
at about 68%.
There was also a newspaper article
that rated the two other
restaurant conversion shows,
and I won't mention
the shows or the hosts,
but there's three of us that
tend to claim this space.
My show ran about a 68% success factor,
the other two were in the 20s.
So I'm very pleased with what we do.
I go at it as a consultant
and the cameras are
along for the trip.
I don't go at it as a TV host
and a consulting is along for the trip.
And I think that's why we're successful.
- All right, cool.
So as I said, I love the show,
so I could talk about it for an hour.
But I do wanna talk
about some other stuff-
- Oh, to answer your question,
I didn't answer your question.
Yes, we did 20 "Back to
the Bar" episodes also.
We went back and looked at them.
And I think those are on
the Paramount website.
And those were sort of fun, too.
- Oh, okay, I'm gonna
have to check those out.
So you mentioned a little
bit about your career
before all this, and
consulting and all that.
When I was doing a little
research this morning,
I saw that you used to
work at the The Troubadour
in West Hollywood.
I used to live about a block from there,
I've been to a bunch of
different events over there.
Can you tell me a little
bit about how you got
into food service, the early
beginnings of your career?
Where your sort of ethos
around personal responsibility
and the rest of it came from?
- Well, when I was young, I
was a very serious musician.
I took drum lessons for nine
years and was very good.
I still have a drum set
upstairs in my office.
I was very good.
I wanted to be a musician.
But my family, and
there's another side of me
that wanted to be going into business.
So to make a long story short,
I went to the University of Denver
and majored in political science
and minored in cultural anthropology,
which I love the study of
primates and what makes us think
and understanding our
primal behaviors and such.
And I started tending bar in college.
And one thing led to another,
and to chase my music career,
and now that I had a bar tending skill,
I went to Los Angeles, got an apartment
in the Oakwood Apartments
in Studio City back then,
which had quite a social hot
tub scene back in those days.
(Dave laughing)
And got a job
in the Troubadour, because
it connected bartending
and music for me.
And then, evolved to be
manager of the Troubadour,
and also worked in Barney's
Beanery down the street,
and managed Barney's Beanery there for-
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, it's still there.
- Sure, sure.
So that was my real beginnings.
When I took over the Troubadour,
we had about eight inches of water
on the floor in the kitchen.
It was flooded, and we had no money.
And Doug Weston, the owner,
may he rest in peace,
back then, had recreational drug habits.
And I would close the Troubadour,
and I'd put $800 or
whatever in the floor safe,
and I'd have to come back
at 8:30 in the morning
to get that $800 out
to pay for the liquor,
'cause everything was COD
'cause we had no credit.
And I'd come in the morning
and the money would be gone,
'cause Doug took it for
drugs the night before.
So I had to run this business
in the most unfavorable of ways.
I had no money, he kept taking the money.
I started taking it home at night
so he couldn't get it in the morning.
I had a flood in the kitchen
that we didn't have the money to fix.
I got pallets, wooden pallets.
We threw 'em on the kitchen floor
so we could walk over the water.
And that's how we opened the Troubadour.
And I coordinated something
called the 25th anniversary
of the Troubadour, and we got everybody
from George Carlin, to Linda Ronstadt,
all of them to come
back during that month,
and we made the money and
stabilized operations.
- Wow, that's incredible.
So then, from there, where did you go?
What are those missing years between that
and what we know from you now?
- So from there, actually,
I worked in Barney's Beanery
a short time before the Troubadour.
Then went to the Troubadour.
Then from the Troubadour, I got an offer
to be a state manager
for a restaurant chain
out of Florida, called
Beefsteak Charlie's,
believe it or not.
- Oh yeah,
I remember Beefsteak Charlies.
- And they had the huge
salad bar and all that.
And I thought that was exciting
to learn the food business.
So I went and I did that.
And I worked down in Florida,
ran their Fort Lauderdale restaurant
and a couple of other
restaurants in Florida.
And then I received a phone
call from a head hunter.
And this one changed my life.
And I was recruited to go up and be a food
and beverage director at Grossinger's,
the largest resort in
America, upstate New York.
1,700 guest rooms, three
nine-hole golf courses,
our own lake, our own ski mountain,
America's first snow making equipment.
So I went up there and now I'm running-
- Is that Catskills?
Is that Catskills?
- Catskill Mountains, you bet.
Grossinger's, two biggies were
the Concord and Grossinger's
up there, so I worked at Grossinger's,
I worked for the family, and
was food and beverage director
and worked there for a few years.
Really learned the resort business,
the convention business
and the hotel business.
So now I had run a nightclub, a great bar,
a chain of steakhouses,
and now I'm running food
and beverage at a large
convention resort hotel.
That rounded out my
experience pretty well.
I got a phone call from
the same head hunger
a couple years later,
said, "Jon, I got a client
who's building the greatest
nightclub in the world.
He wants you to come run it."
And his name was Leon
Altemose in Philadelphia,
and he was creating Pulsations nightclub.
And Pulsations nightclub
had a 4 1/2 ton spaceship,
27 feet in diameter.
People can Google it online,
that came down and
dropped a $400,000 robot
on the dance floor.
And it was the greatest
nightclub in the world.
I worked on that for a few years,
opening and operating
Pulsations nightclub.
And now I had run a mega venue.
And from Grossinger's, then
I started my own company.
Actually, I'm forgetting a step.
From Grossinger's, I was hired
by a hotel management company
out of Chicago called P&S Management.
And I was a hotel general manager
and then a Vice President
of Sales and Marketing
for this company that had 28
hotels for about four years.
When I left that company, that was 1986,
I started my own consulting company,
'cause tax codes had changed, Dave,
and hotels couldn't write
off the things they used
to write off now.
So restaurants had to make money,
they couldn't be guest amenities anymore.
Bars had to make money.
These had to be profit
centers, not just amenities.
So I left that company,
started my own company,
Taffer Dynamics, and my first
client was that company.
So they let me start
my company and gave me
a number of contracts.
And then in 1989, I built
my first owned operation
in St. Louis, a place called Lynn Dickeys
in St. Louis Union Station.
And then from there I was approached
by Simon Property Group
to do a few restaurants
in Mall of America in Minnesota.
So I went up to Minneapolis,
I opened the Alamo Grill,
Gators, an original sports bar,
another concept that we worked on
up in Mall of America.
That one really changed my life.
And then I took Alamo Grill,
turned it into a chain of steakhouses,
took it public, then reversed it
into another public company and left
with stock in a huger Canadian entity.
And then I was in business.
I had owned, I had taken in public,
I had run hotels, bars,
restaurants, concert venues.
I had taken companies public,
taken companies profit.
I was really ready.
And that, of course, was a long time ago.
So since then, I've consulted
to some of the greatest
companies in the world.
So I always tell people
during my consulting practice
in young years, I made every
mistake there was to make.
And that's why I got really good at it.
And now I am.
I'm probably one of the
best at it in the world.
It's funny, 'cause when I hear you talk
about your resume, it's like, wow,
the fact that I really only know this guy
as a sort of reality TV host,
but it's a lot of decades of stuff.
I mean, you just went across
the food service industry
and did pretty much...
Is there anything you didn't do?
Like, do you see any
holes in that industry
that you really didn't
do or weren't part of?
- No, I know every type of venue
from concert venues to outdoor arenas,
inside venues, fine dining restaurants,
casual dining, fast food.
I mean, I've been in
every one of these sectors
as either an owner,
operator, management company
or consultant, I really
do know every aspect
of this business.
And make no mistake, Dave, that helps.
And I think it's very
important that people
in casual dining have an
understanding of upscale dining
because they impact each other.
And there are things in service sequencing
and things that one can learn
in one segment from another,
or one category from another.
Fast food is another great example.
The transactional style
of fast food now has
to exist in full service restaurants
because of COVID and contactless.
And so I think that broadness
of appeal has really helped me,
particularly my hotel
background and resort background
has been really helpful for me.
- Can you talk about just
some of the basic principles
that you try to bring
to any of the businesses
that you're coaching or working on?
Because as I said, since we're doing this
as small business week, we're gonna talk
to people, not just in
the food service industry,
but just some of the
principles that you think
actually build solid, strong businesses
that can actually survive when we go
through terrible situations
like we're going through right now.
- I think that a couple of things.
One, I don't think that
you're doing a podcast
or a broadcast right now,
I don't believe that.
I don't believe that's your product.
I believe that's your vehicle.
Your product is reactions.
If your audience doesn't
react to what you do,
then it serves no purpose.
So you're not in the content business,
you're in the reaction business.
Content is your vehicle,
it's not your product.
That's the first thing I
learned when I was younger.
That cook in the kitchen
is not making an entree.
He's not making a product.
He's creating a reaction.
He's the vehicle.
When that plate hits the table, Dave,
one of two things happens.
Either you sit up and you
react to it, or you don't.
That reaction is the product.
So I suggest the cell phones companies
don't sell technology,
they sell reactions.
They achieve it through technology.
I suggest that every business
is in the reaction business.
I own the term reaction management.
My first book, "Raise the Bar"
was all about reaction
management and understanding.
And this comes out
of my cultural anthropology
training as well.
Understanding the primal
instincts of what you react to
as a consumer.
So I believe that we don't play music,
we play reactions, we
achieve it through music.
We don't make drinks, we make reactions.
We achieve it through drinks.
So I am in the business of
creating human reactions,
period, end of discussion.
And he or she who creates
the best reactions
in my business wins, end of story.
That's the business that we're in.
Now, we can dissect
that into connectivity,
and engagement, and pace, and environment.
But every one of those things
has to create reaction.
Pace is about reaction.
Go to a fine steakhouse.
They walk really slow.
Go to a Denny's, they walk really fast.
If the waiter walks too
fast in a fine steakhouse
that steak isn't worth $80 anymore, is it?
So these things all affect reactions.
And reactions drive consumer behavior.
Reactions drive transactions.
Period.
It isn't the other way around.
So when I take a look at the
whole science of reactions,
then in our corporate training,
we created something else
as a term that we own called GROWs.
GROW stands for guest
reaction opportunity windows.
In other businesses we call it CROWs.
Customer reaction opportunity windows.
Points where I can
create a reaction in you.
I spec 'em, I design 'em
right into the business.
I wanna design this
right into that business.
So I'm designing, not a plate,
I'm designing a reaction.
And I'll design that
plate 100 frickin' times
until you sit up.
And that's the business
that we are all in.
And he or she, no matter
what business that we're in,
are gonna create the
best reactions of all.
Now, if we take a look
at the current situation
we're right now, if we can talk
about the pandemic for
a moment or two, Dave.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- I said this four months ago,
and I was one of the first ones to say it,
and research now shows that I was 2% off.
When this started I said, people are gonna
come back in thirds.
The first third is the quick 1/3.
They're gonna come right out
again when the doors open.
They're younger, they're
a little fearless.
They're gonna come out,
they might not wear a mask.
We're seeing that first 1/3 now.
According to research, it's 31%.
I projected 1/3.
The second 1/3 I call the reserved 1/3.
They wanna watch for a couple weeks.
They wanna see what happens.
Is there a surge?
How do the restaurants look?
Does it look safe?
Are people wearing masks, are they not?
If it feels good and looks good,
the reserved 1/3 will go out.
Now we've got 2/3.
The third 1/3 is the certain 1/3.
They're not going anywhere
until they are certain
that they're safe.
So a vaccine, a rock solid treatment needs
to emerge before they'll come out.
The issue is that the
third 1/3 has the money.
It tends to be an older demographic,
a more affluent demographic,
greater disposable income number.
They tend to feed the luxury sector
more than the first
1/3 and the second 1/3.
So there's a demographic reality
to this as these businesses
shuffle through it.
For example, I'm here in Las Vegas,
we've been open for about a week.
We're doing pretty well.
But we're finding the
first customers who come
are value-oriented.
They're coming, they're that first 1/3,
they're younger, they
don't have high dispose,
so they're very value-oriented,
so we better come out of the
gate with value propositions.
When the second 1/3 comes out-
- What are the kinds of things?
What are the kinds of things
that you guys are doing
in Vegas, or that you're seeing
being done to address that?
- Well, the average casino has
about 800 policy changes in it.
From non-invasive temperature
testing automatically
as you walk through the
door of the property,
to contactless check-in,
to only one or two people
in elevators and are policed and managed
at each elevator floor,
to sanitized chips,
and cards, and when you're
finished with a slot machine
it turns off and it can't turn on again
until it's sanitized.
And there's a lock and a key system on it.
So they've done all sorts of
things to make it successful.
But you know, Dave, what worries me is,
when we look at these thirds,
obviously there's a progress
we need to go through.
And let me ask you a question if I can.
If you were gonna go out to dinner tonight
in a restaurant that was open,
and there was a crowd
of people in that front
of that restaurant, and none
of them were wearing masks,
would you go in?
- So it's interesting.
So I'll tell ya, I have only been
to one restaurant since this all happened.
It was last week, it was a
restaurant right by my house,
just a burger joint bar that
I go to every now and again.
The waitress, I was not
wearing a mask there,
and it was pretty sporadic.
So I was with one person.
The waitress was wearing
a mask and a face guard.
And it's not that comfortable.
You know this.
You need to read people's
faces to feel comfortable,
it feels sort of weird with all that.
I think for me at this
point as a relatively young,
healthy person, if I went
to a nice restaurant,
let's say in Beverly Hills
or something like that,
I would be okay if people
were not wearing stuff.
I actually would be okay with that.
But I don't consider
myself in the last 1/3
that you just talked about.
I think I'm somewhere
between the first 1/3
and the second 1/3, I think.
And also, here is Los Angeles
where we've been closed
for so long, I think
I'm also having, like,
a reverse reaction,
which I think a lot of people are having,
which is like, let's just go.
Let's just go and see what happens, yeah.
- I worry about irresponsibility.
Not on the part of restaurant owners.
I'm concerned, Dave,
that a restaurant does everything right,
it sanitizes, puts their
employees in the proper gear,
does all the procedures in the kitchen,
all the PPE attire, has
everything exactly right,
but then a bunch of customers
come in without masks,
create a bad impression,
pictures go on social media
of this place packed, and
then all of the portion
of society that wants to wear
masks will never go there.
So there's a real challenge
for business today.
And I think I know the answer,
but I'm not quite sure
if my answer is right.
And this is deep, Dave,
if you were in a bar
business and you said, okay,
I'm gonna play country music.
No rock-and-roll people are coming.
You've made a decision
that's gonna completely
segment your business
to country people only.
So you're gonna see some boots,
you're gonna see some hats,
you're not gonna see a lot
of Armani suits, probably,
and it's gonna be a country environment.
Let's say you chose, ah,
I don't wanna do that.
I'm gonna play rock-and-roll in my bar.
Okay, no country people there.
No hip hop people there.
You just segmented your business
to a portion of the population.
Let's say you say, I'm gonna play hip hop.
Same deal, no country, no rock,
you segmented yourself
into a certain segment
of the population.
My point is this.
There's the mask wearers and
there's the non-mask wearers.
And I think that
restaurants are gonna be put
in a position where they're
gonna have to choose.
Just like that music segmentation.
Either you have to wear
a mask in my restaurant
when you're not eating,
you have to wear a mask
when you're wearing outside, or you don't.
But I don't think mixing
it is gonna work long-term.
And that's a really tough choice.
And nobody's talking about
this is the industry.
Do it or don't do it.
What do we have to do?
And it's a segmenting decision,
just like music is, or price points are.
So I'm of the belief that
restaurants need to pick.
And I'm of the belief for
long-term sustainability.
And here's what I worry about.
We are living in a culture
of accountability today.
People go out, have a bad
meal, it's all over Yelp
in a matter of minutes.
Right?
So if people get sick in a restaurant
and it's traced back
to a restaurant, done.
Case closed, that place
will never open again.
In New York, they're gonna
take liquor licenses away
if customers act irresponsibly.
So we're at a turning
point as an industry.
Are we gonna allow the
behavior of customers
to destroy our investment?
Or are we gonna regulate that behavior?
The nightclub business has
been doing this for years
by segmenting by music,
segmenting by dress codes,
and doing segmentation.
We've survived in a segmented world
since I got in this business
all these years ago.
I don't believe that we
can succeed as an industry
if we don't choose what side we're on.
And if we choose to run in
an unprotected environment,
and choose to not do
some of these processes
that can keep people safe,
we may pay the ultimate price.
And the ultimate price is not
only getting somebody sick
or potentially killing them,
but destroying your business.
So I take an opposite position to you.
And I'm not sure that I would let you
in my restaurant or stand in
front of it without a mask.
- Yeah, and I totally hear you.
It's a personal choice, not only
for the individual consumer, but obviously
for the owner of the bar or restaurant.
Do you think what makes
it even more muddled,
what confuses it even more
is that it's one thing
if you're walking into a clothing store
and you're wearing a mask,
well, you're not using your mouth.
You're not using your face.
At a restaurant it's
like, well, wait a minute.
I can walk in, I have to
wear a mask, let's say,
when I walk in, but we
do know I have to drink
through my mouth, I have
to eat through my mouth.
So there is these sort of inconsistencies
where it's like, people are just like,
well, then, why am I doing it at all?
Like, it's just the natural
questions that arise.
- Well, if there's spacing at the tables
and people are standing
in front of the restaurant
without that level of spacing,
I think it's reasonable for us to say,
we'd appreciate you wearing
a mask until you're seated.
Seems like a simple definition.
My worry is this.
If I had, and I said this on "Bar Rescue",
if there's 60 motorcycles
in front of a bar,
there's a bunch of people
that won't go to that bar.
If there's a bunch of people dressed
in gang colors in front of a bar,
there's people who won't go in that bar.
Today, if there's a bunch of people
in front of a bar that look irresponsible
as it relates to COVID,
there are customers
that won't go in that bar.
It's no different.
So when you say about how
are we gonna be successful,
there's two issues.
There's that issue.
And all of that is driven
by this one premise.
And bear with me for a minute, Dave.
If you, you're a burger guy, right?
You love a good burger?
- Yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
- So let's say that your
favorite burger place in town
after this pandemic, you go walk up to it,
everybody's packed in there,
they're not wearing masks,
they're not even wearing
masks behind the counter,
the whole thing just doesn't feel right.
But two blocks farther away
is your second favorite
burger place, father,
but they're clean, they're tight,
their staff is in masks, I
mean this place is together.
It looks great, it's safe.
You're now gonna go to your
second favorite burger place
which is farther away than
you're first burger place.
Dave, that changes everything.
Trust has now ratcheted to the top.
So now you're gonna walk farther
to go to your second
favorite burger place,
'cause your first favorite burger place
didn't gain your trust.
That's powerful.
- Yeah, well,
it's interesting because
you're talking about
free market capitalism, and
also talking about rules.
But ultimately you're
saying it's on people
to make the right choices.
- So, if in fact, trust is ratcheting up
to the top of the motivation
list of what businesses
I choose to do business with,
how do we build trust?
And this goes back to your question,
how do we get successful now?
Well, if we know that we have thirds,
then if we know we have to build trust,
even for you who's quicker to go out,
maybe, than I am, then
how do we build trust?
Well, trust isn't words, trust
isn't advertising campaigns.
Trust is transparency.
You begin to trust me as an individual
once you get to know me a little, right?
Trust is built.
So trust is a very difficult emotion
to build in a person.
So we need to be transparent.
So the way we create transparency is
by creating visual
standards of what people see
and what they can expect in our business.
So for example, a few weeks
ago on my social media,
Dave, and some guy's making
lasagna in a kitchen.
And he posts a picture of a cook,
and he's standing in this
stainless steel line,
and he's laying a lasagna
noodle in the pan.
And the post says, "Our
famous lasagna will be ready
for curbside pickup at five o'clock."
Pretty noble effort, right?
Guy's not wearing a mask.
He's wearing a ball cap from home.
He's wearing clear, cheap plastic gloves
that somebody wears in a
salon when they do hair color.
It's not even food service rated.
All the imaging is wrong.
So if we don't build trust,
nobody's gonna eat that frickin' lasagna.
So we as an industry
have to really understand
how to build trust.
What are the marketing
communications of trust?
When you walk up to the
front door of my business,
retail, restaurant, bar,
what looks different?
Oh, they changed this.
And subliminally you're saying,
well, they changed it for me.
They're keeping me safe.
This is a good thing.
Oh, I feel good about this.
I like this.
Okay, from one little thing,
all of these assumptions
go through your head.
So what has to be different?
I suggest that every business
needs to change something.
They need to change their seating layout,
they need to change signage in the front,
they need to put a podium
out front for check in,
they need to do something
that sends the message
of trust in a transparent way.
If I can send the message
of trust in this world,
I can get the first 1/3, the second 1/3,
and the third 1/3.
If trust, if that first
1/3 slams out social media
with untrusting visuals, you're gonna have
a hell of a time getting
into second and third 1/3.
- So where do you think
government and regulation
kind of fit into this?
Because we're hearing all
sorts of arbitrary things,
or seemingly arbitrary things every week,
depending on where you live.
Okay, we can be at 50%
restaurant capacity,
but that's regardless whether you've
done all of these precautions or not
done all of these precautions.
And I'm sure you must be hearing
from owners of restaurants and bars
who are saying hey, I'll do everything
that I possibly can do.
I'll put all the investment in,
we'll do all the work,
but if we can only open at 50% capacity,
there's no way we can succeed regardless
of doing everything or
not doing everything.
- Well, and I don't disagree with you.
So new revenue centers need to be found,
hence delivery, curbside pickup.
But these third party delivery apps
are destroying our industry.
And they're the only
people who make money.
Pay them 25, up to 35%
third party delivery apps.
So I beg people on this podcast,
if you wanna do a to-go order
or a curbside delivery order,
call the restaurant directly.
Don't call one of these
third party sources.
It's a huge deal to them.
It's a huge difference in
the way they make money.
So we have to create
these new opportunities
for revenue models.
So I have a friend, Tiffany Derry,
you've seen her, chef Tiffany
Derry on "Bar Rescue".
Her restaurant now does family meal packs
for four to go.
And for $39 you get an amazing meal
with potatoes, and vegetables,
and chicken, and soup.
So she's come up with a new
way to package her product.
We take a look at, I
was on a consulting call
with a big brewery in Canada,
and they have a
merchandising program called
From Tap to Table.
Doesn't work anymore.
Now, it's From Tap to Home.
We gotta get our brand home.
We gotta get the delivery packaging.
We gotta get our brand to move.
So I'm with you, Dave,
but here's the problem.
I'm at 50% capacity,
so I have to, if I'm at half the capacity,
I have to double my hours of revenue.
So an hour and a half for lunch
doesn't work for me anymore.
I need three hours of lunch now.
So I need to do early bird lunch specials,
late bird lunch specials,
early bird dinner.
I gotta generate more hours
to offset my loss in capacity.
So I gotta look at
that, which means I have
to do some promotional activity.
Free this, free that, get this $2 off
to drive more hours of traffic.
The problem is, I've also
increased my labor costs,
'cause now I'm doing in three hours
what I used to do in one
hour, and hour and a half.
So it affects the whole economic model.
Here's my point.
We have two challenges in
front of us as an industry.
One is to sustain ourselves during this.
And the second is to have the resources
to launch properly when it ends.
If we spend all of our
money sustaining ourselves,
Dave, we are never gonna reopen
with the resources to win.
If we hold back our sustaining dollars now
and hold them for when
we can open properly,
I personally think that's
the better scenario.
And I've found for very
of my many friends,
sure, we wanna keep our employees working,
we wanna do everything we can.
But it might make sense
to close for a few weeks
and open with a real marketing plan,
and an activation plan,
and a promotion plan,
and open with a bang later when we have
the potential to do so.
It's hard to spend the
money to do anything
with a bang when you're
locked at 50% capacity.
The other thing that you said
which was important to me was,
what do we do, what are the standards?
25%, 50%, blah, blah, blah.
So I think it's paramount,
and I know the NRA, National
Restaurant Association
not rifle, I know that the NRA...
I always get hate notes when
I put NRA on social media.
- I had a buddy in the
food service industry
who was always telling me
to go into the NRA meetings.
I think they were in Chicago,
and it was always very confusing,
but we figured it out.
- Yes. But you know what?
They've put together
some wonderful programs
and standards that we can follow
to assure consumer safety.
I think that there needs to
be some federal standard.
I do, I believe that.
And the problem with the governors today,
tangle with the federal government now,
there's an ego thing, there's
a push and pull in power,
we're more divisive than ever before.
So a democratic governor
is not gonna listen
to a republican president no
matter what the standards are.
If he says 50%, they're doing 25.
And I'm not being political here.
But there are standards that make sense,
and the disease can be
contracted just as easily
in Florida as it can Oklahoma.
There's no chemical difference
between the disease and those places.
So if there was a standard that was safe,
a national standard, you and I could start
to feel comfortable with that standard.
So I think that that's the
problem is you don't know
what to expect.
And every state is a
free-for-all in standards.
I think we need a national program, I do.
And I'm just not sure the
states would agree to it,
but I'm pushing for it very heavily
that defines space requirements,
distancing requirements,
food service, back of
the house requirements,
so that everybody knows that
it's an even playing field.
Every restaurant is in
the same playing field,
the same economic modeling,
the same consumer presence,
it all changes.
Years ago, Dave, I can remember
when Tempe, Arizona put
a no smoking policy in place.
It was a little town.
Nobody else around it did.
Every bar went broke when that happened.
You can't do things.
Guy that lives on the
Tennessee/Kentucky border,
the guy in Tennessee is making a fortune,
the guy in Kentucky is starving.
They're across the street from each other,
just the regulations are different.
That doesn't work in the
business environment.
I think we need to
level the playing field,
create some national
standard of behavior for us
that's predictable to you.
So you know whether you
go to Dave's restaurant
or Jon's restaurant, it's gonna have
the same policies in place.
We have to get to that
point somehow, I believe.
Do you?
- Do you think when we get,
- I'm curious to hear your opinion.
- So, well, it's interesting.
As a general rule, I'm a
big states' right guys.
So I want the states to be able
to set whatever regulations as possible,
because then the experiment
sort of bounces around.
But as I say on this show all the time,
something like coronavirus
or any virus doesn't respond
to states' borders,
so I think we need something
that blends both state
and federal would be my
short answer on that.
- And I'm with you.
I'm very state rights oriented,
and local as well.
But I think in this position,
the problem is that the actions,
and I'm just picking Tennessee,
I have no issues with Tennessee,
the issues, if somebody works in Tennessee
and lives in Kentucky,
the policies in Tennessee
could be impacted in
the state of Kentucky.
So I think there is a
cross responsibility here,
particularly near the borders
that we have some standards
of behaviors so that no state,
town, or person is disadvantaged.
That seems reasonable to me.
- Yeah, well, it's always a matter of,
how do you get there?
I suspect we all wanna
get to the same thing,
which is people back to work
and enjoying themselves.
Do you think, regardless of how the third,
third, third shake out,
I can sort of see everything
going one of two ways.
One way would be, which would be terrible
for the economy and certainly
for the food service industry would be
that people have now just new behaviors.
We're used to bringing
in food all the time,
most of us are cooking
more one way or another,
and that that behavior
will just sort of continue.
Or there's another part of me,
and I hope it goes more to this,
where when we really are
on the other side of this,
that there's more of a
roaring '20s feeling.
We are in the '20s now,
and there will be more
of a feeling of, like,
yeah, let's remember what it was like
to go out there and go
to a bar and hang out
with your friends and
meet some new people,
or go to your favorite restaurant.
I'm really missing BOA
Steakhouse on Sunset.
Like, to do that kinda stuff,
do you sense we will go
one way or the other?
- I do.
But I think it might get
split by those thirds
a little bit.
I think that the sting
is gonna last longer
for people of an older demo.
I just do.
And I think that if I
were to do a prediction,
I think the luxury dining sector is gonna
be the most challenged.
I think they're gonna be
the last ones to come out.
Even though they tend
to have more spread dining rooms anyway,
they probably lose less seating
with six-foot separation
because the tables
aren't bunched like in a
casual dining environment.
I'm very concerned, there's
a way to look at this, too.
Let's say we do lose 30 to 40%
of our restaurants and bars.
Well, in theory, we now
have 40% less capacity
and seating, but we have
about the same marketplace.
So I think that the ones that survive
might actually survive into
a very vibrant marketplace.
And I think I agree with you
on a roaring '20s analogy.
But I think we need to get to a vaccine
and a place where that
safety is somewhat assured.
- How worried are you
that small businesses,
the guy that just wants
to make a great bar,
a great restaurant, not a franchise,
not a big business, but the guy
that wants, in his hometown,
to just put the greatest
restaurant ever there.
That they will have
looked at what happened
over the last year and
be like, you know what?
The risk, risks always, I'm
sure you know the numbers
for restaurants and bars,
if you wanna tell everybody
the failure rates,
they're always absurdly high.
But now, the risks seem
almost incalculably high
for people to wanna get in on this.
- It's interesting that you mention.
I own a franchise called Taffer's Tavern.
And we created this franchise,
you'll find this interesting,
and I'm not doing this as a plug.
We, two years ago, had no labor pool.
We were approaching $15 minimum wages,
and the labor pool that we did have
were mostly new Americans who
didn't speak English so well.
So I said, "I gotta create
the casual dining concept
of the future."
So I wanna cut labor costs in half,
I wanna bring in robotic cooking,
robotic ovens, eliminate
back of the house,
create this whole new restaurant model.
So I did.
I worked with companies like Middlby
and worked in test kitchens
around the country,
and created this kitchen of
the future concept a year ago.
Created, called Taffer's Tavern,
did our franchise registration,
started to franchise.
COVID happens.
We find out we don't have any raw protein
in our restaurant.
It's all sous vide cooking.
Everything is individually wrapped,
prepared in computerized ovens.
It's really high quality.
So we don't have raw, uncooked product.
We don't have grease.
We don't even have hoods.
So we have a very different cooking model.
It is the kitchen of the future.
We are the most COVID-safe
kitchen in the world.
We didn't even design it this way.
So now we put uniforms
on our kitchen staff,
we have cameras in the kitchen
so you can see your food be
prepared right on your phone,
and we created the safest,
cleanest kitchen concept
in the country, starting
on a whole different basis.
So I launched my franchise,
and I'm answering your question for you,
'cause this is interesting, Dave,
and we sold a bunch of franchises.
We sold Washington, we sold Atlanta,
a whole bunch of territories.
We're doing very, very well.
The franchise is going.
COVID hits, shoop, sales
stop at franchises.
About 45 days later we get a phone call
from some people that say, "Listen,
we're a franchise company.
We're interested in buying
your franchise and here's why.
We wanna buy it now because we think
that some of the greatest
restaurant locations
in America are become available
in the next 90 days.
And we wanna jump on those locations
with a concept that has good,
solid economic modeling."
And I never quite thought that way.
So we just sold the city of Boston,
we just sold the city of Washington DC
to sophisticated developers who are now
dropping them in places like Faneuil Hall,
'cause these locations
have become available.
My point is this.
There's opportunity now.
And the industry is
gonna go through a shift,
there's no question about it.
But there's great locations that are gonna
be available now.
There's aggressive
landlords who will give you
very aggressive deals right now
with tenant allowant packages,
and free rent for a year or two.
I mean, they will bend over
backwards to do those deals.
So to that fictitious restaurant guy
that we were just talking about
who's scared to do it, maybe
this is the time to do it.
And I put a fascinating
thought model out there.
Now, we have a big to-go element
that we've put in in Taffer's Tavern
and a curbside element, so
we've shifted the business model
post-COVID, obviously, Dave.
But my point is this.
If you've ever wanted to be
in a restaurant business,
one of the highest costs we got is
occupancy and construction.
Today, there's unbelievable
opportunity out there.
Don't just think that COVID
is bad for the industry.
It could be good for the industry, too.
For some people, in the end.
Interesting view, isn't it?
- Yeah, well, chaos
always brings opportunity.
I'm actually glad you brought
up the automated kitchen
and mentioned a little
bit about the economics
of some of this, 'cause it is something
that I talk about a lot on the show,
relative to minimum
wage and the rest of it.
So for you, as a guy that want,
I know you wanna employ people,
you want people to feel empowered,
and feel like they have some control
in their lives and all that,
when you're making those decisions to go,
well, wait a minute.
I can't pay these people $15 an hour
because technically they're not worth it
if they don't speak the
language and all that,
without getting into all
the specifics of that,
do you have sort of like a,
almost like a philosophical struggle there
between how to go ahead
and do a new business
that isn't gonna hire as
many people, potentially,
but is gonna be more of, say,
a restaurant of the future?
And something that's sustainable.
That's your whole point.
- Honestly, no.
And of course there's a personal factor.
You wanna hire as many people as you can.
My proudest day is when I
had about 900 employees.
And I used to think to myself every night,
I put about 1,000 meals
on the table every day.
I was really proud of that.
But today, my responsibility
is to sustain the jobs
of the people that work for me.
To provide them with an
opportunity that is consistent,
it's gonna last and provide
them with a good income.
Bigger doesn't necessarily
mean more stable.
Doesn't mean more income for everyone.
Also, what about the guy
who built all the robotics?
Who programmed all the systems?
They got jobs that didn't have 'em before.
So I don't think I'm eliminating jobs.
I think I'm redistributing
those jobs a little bit
into technology plays rater
than just straight cook lines.
But I think that the restaurant industry
is being challenged unlike others.
There's many states where tipped employees
get paid about $2.20 an hour.
And it's an employee tip credit of,
whatever it is, $13 an hour,
to adjust their payroll down.
So these employees typically make 20,
30, $40 an hour in tips
in many of these places.
So they make $2.20 an hour in payroll.
From $2.20 an hour to $15
is a 600% payroll increase.
There is no business in the world
that can sustain a 600% payroll increase.
So I'm trying to protect my industry.
I'm trying to protect the people that work
in the industry by creating
a stable economic model.
There is no guilt in stability.
There is no guilt in
following economic models
that provide prosperity
for those who work for us.
It isn't my choice.
I'd much rather be hiring more people.
But it isn't something
I have any guilt about.
- Yeah, I love the answer.
I mean, that's the honest answer.
And unfortunately, we've got a lot
of business owners these
days that would give you
the guilt answer to just
sort of pretend they're
doing the right thing as opposed
to actually doing the right thing.
If somebody's watching this right now
and they're young and they always wanted
to get into the biz,
you talked about a long resume
of doing basically everything.
What would you recommend?
I mean, is the first job
just to be a barback?
Or do you have, like, a specific idea
on how they get in on this?
- Yeah, I think the
most important two jobs
are a line cook and a barback.
You learn everything
from those two positions.
Or bartender.
So I'm of the belief
that you should not go
into this business until
you at least tend bar
and work in the kitchen.
Those are the two areas
where waste occurs,
those are the two areas
where theft occurs,
those are the two hearts of the business.
If it breaks down there,
in either of those places,
you have no business.
The worst thing in the world
in the restaurant industry
is to be held hostage to ignorance.
I can't tell you how many friends I've had
over the years that
have opened restaurants
that have never been in a business before,
they hire a chef, they pay him
x amount of dollars a year,
they're open 60 days, the chef says,
this is all on me, I want
equity or I'm leaving,
and the guy who owns it doesn't
know how to cook a steak
or doesn't even know
one of his own recipes.
He's held hostage by his ignorance.
This is a challenging business.
Think of a retail store,
but the T-shirts go bad after three days.
How 'bout that?
Imagine a T-shirt shop that they rot away
after three or four days.
There's theft.
So we have to manage production,
we have to manage retail,
manage merchandising,
manage staff, manage purchasing.
It's a very difficult business.
And you can't do it from
a point of ignorance.
Those are the people who fail.
And it's interesting, Dave,
'cause if you look at the statistics,
about one in eight restaurants succeed
for a first-time operator.
Seven of eight succeed
for the second time.
- Wow.
- It's a fascinating shift
to the statistics.
So once you made those
mistakes the first time,
Dave, you're sorta ready now.
But without the experience,
you're not in a very
good statistical place.
With the experience,
you're in a far better statistical place.
- What resources can we send people to?
Are you still doing
seminars on all of this?
- Oh, sure.
Yeah, sure, we still do seminars.
You can go to Jontaffer.com.
Matter of fact, we're working
on an industry webinar
in the next couple weeks.
So you can go visit Jontaffer.com.
There's great resources out
there for restaurant people.
Please go to the National
Restaurant Association site.
They have wonderful COVID information,
great marketing programs and such.
There's another organization,
the Nightclub and Bar
Show and Media Group,
which also has great information on it.
And then, of course, we have our TVT,
which is about 40 hours
of training content,
marketing, promotion that
we have that's available
on our website also.
My point is this.
When this pandemic started,
and I'd like to sort of be
positive here for a minute, Dave.
When this pandemic started,
I saw people get paralyzed.
They didn't know what to do.
They were frozen.
My second book about excuses,
which we talked about,
I realized that at this time,
great marketers are gonna
bubble to the top, aren't they?
We're gonna see some amazing stuff.
Great promoters are
gonna bubble to the top.
We're gonna see great activations,
and programs, and online events.
Great operators are
gonna bubble to the top.
We're gonna see incredible
things happen out there.
So this is a time to
mobilize, not paralyze.
This is a time to think
about what it takes
to bubble to the top.
Dare I say, those of us who perceive this
as an opportunity and act upon it,
can turn this into an opportunity.
Those of us who freeze,
who say, ah, this isn't the time,
I believe we're gonna be left behind.
This is all up to us, not the pandemic.
It is up to us.
Don't let this pandemic be the excuse,
and we talked about that earlier.
That's just making yourself feel warm,
well, it's the pandemic
that caused me to fail.
And I'm gonna say it, bullshit.
It's up to us.
And at a time like this,
we can figure out how to be successful.
And a lot of restaurants
are gonna do that.
- Well, Jon, I don't know that I've ever
felt better about what I do for a living,
because you didn't yell
at me once in 50 minutes.
So must be doing okay over here.
- Well, you're a great host, buddy.
You have a great cast and I'm proud
to be here with you.
But I think you do wonderful work.
And I think anybody who
listens to your podcast
always learns something about themselves
and their business.
So keep up the good work, my friend.
- Well, I really appreciate it.
And listen, I'm gonna be
in Vegas in a couple weeks
for Freedom Fest.
And if you've got a little time,
I'd love to take you out for a drink,
or a steak, or whatever
you're doing these days.
Oh wait, you're probably
not gonna be want,
are you gonna wanna go out?
- There's a few places
I'll go to, there's a
few places I'll go to.
You bet, you bet.
- It's on me, man.
Well, I really appreciate
it, thanks a lot.
- My pleasure. Nice talking to you, Dave.
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles,
instead of non-stop yelling,
check out our lifestyle playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.